what we really designed mama for was for
the broad exchange between industry and
the academic community AI and
reinforcement learning are fascinating
techniques and this whole area is
developing very very quickly but it's
not quite clear where the next new
insight is going to come from so we were
really envisioning this as a meta
platform that others could be using to
start to compare start to integrate the
different approaches and really generate
new insights and understanding how to
push this area for it you're listening
to the Microsoft Research podcast a show
that brings you closer to the cutting
edge of technology research and the
scientists behind it I'm your host
Gretchen using
[Music]
the wildly popular video game Minecraft
might appear to be an unlikely candidate
for machine learning research but to dr.
Katja Hoffman the research lead of
project Malmo in the machine
intelligence and perception group at
Microsoft Research in Cambridge England
it's the perfect environment for
teaching AI agents via reinforcement
learning to act intelligently and
cooperatively in the open world today
dr. Hoffman talks about her vision of a
future where machines learn to
collaborate with people and empower them
to help solve complex real-world
problems she also shares the story of
how her early years in East Germany
behind the Iron Curtain shaped her both
personally and professionally and
ultimately facilitated a creative
exploratory mindset about computing that
informs her work to this day that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
katja Hoffman welcome to the podcast
thanks for having me you're a researcher
in the machine intelligence group in
Cambridge give us a brief description of
the work you do and the things you're
working on in broad strokes what gets
you up in the morning I broadly work in
the area of mighty agent reinforcement
learning so I look at how artificial
agents can learn to interact with
complex environments and I'm
particularly excited about possibilities
of those environments being ones where
they interact with humans so one area is
for example in video games where AI
agents that learn to interact
intelligently could really enrich video
games and create new types of
experiences for example learn directly
from their interactions with players
remember what kinds of interactions
they've had and be really more relatable
and more responsive to what is actually
going on in the game and how they're
interacting with the player so let's
drill in there just a little bit what
you're talking about
is what I think you call collaborative
AI tell us a little bit more about what
this is and why it's an important line
of inquiry in the broader field of AI
research I think of collaborative a is
really one of the key questions in
artificial intelligence so when we think
about machines that learn or mention
machines that perform certain tasks the
end goal of this is always in my mind a
machine that is better at helping us
achieve what we want to achieve so I
really think about AI researchers coming
up with new ways to enable this
collaboration between machines and
humans in a huge variety of different
applications I think that in general
techniques like machine learning
reinforcement learning are particularly
promising for pushing that forward and
enabling new kinds of collaborations but
what I envision in the future are
machines that understand what we're
trying to do and that can really reason
about what it is that is most helpful to
us to support us and achieving more yes
this kind of resonates with a lot of
research that's going on here at
Microsoft research specifically this
idea of augment versus replace talk to
me a little bit more about
the augmenting where this application is
most fruitful for us do you think the
application area that I think about the
most is video games and I see video
games as an important stepping stone
towards enabling more general
applications of collaborative AI I think
in the long term there are a huge number
of different applications starting from
health to being creative but I think for
many of those applications some of the
key research questions we're still
trying to address are very very hard to
address in these open-ended real world
environments and video games form this
really interesting intermediate stage
where we have very complex worlds that
are extremely rich that are really
engaging for people and we have a lot of
scenarios where people interact and
small or large communities within those
fantastic worlds so there is this space
for introducing new technology for
understanding how agents within video
games could learn to collaborate with
people and then we can once
well-understood take this technology and
apply it to new application areas I want
to talk about this exciting application
of collaborative AI that you've really
poured a lot of time and effort into
called project Malmo tell us about it
absolutely so project mano is an AI
experimentation platform that my team
and I built on top of the popular video
game minecraft and when we started
developing this project we were really
thinking about what would the future
platform for AI research looked like so
what features what capabilities would we
need to support not just addressing the
next research questions that were
immediately focusing on but that would
enable a huge number of researchers and
whose desks to explore the space and
push AI research forward for the next 10
15 years to come so we built a very
generic platform on top of this
minecraft game to allow researchers to
create different new tasks to put
different kinds of agents into the game
and to really push the state of the art
forward so why did you choose Minecraft
to launch this platform minecraft seemed
the perfect fit for project like this if
you've played minecraft before you'll
know that it's kind of the sandbox game
it's almost like a meta game where
different communities different players
go in and create amazing artifacts and
new games within this game there's a
concept of parkour races where people
set up kind of race courses to race
against their friends and there's build
battles where you have to construct
creative new structures so people are
using this sandbox game to come up with
all these different ways of playing and
interacting with each other and if you
think about a general purpose platform
for AI evaluation then this is exactly
what we need we need to be able to have
a platform that is general enough so
that we can create some initial tasks
that push the current state of the art
in reinforcement learning or AI and more
generally and then be able to expand
that build on that to create more and
more complex more more challenging tasks
to throw at our agents to really push
them moving forward their tasks and
they're around navigation that are at
the level that can be addressed by
current state-of-the-art approaches all
the way to a task that would require a
complex communication interaction in
natural language and we can support all
those different scenarios within the
platform let's get into the weeds a
little bit about the technology behind
Malmo and what kinds of methodologies
approaches techniques are you using to
do this research
so my team here is particularly
interested in this area called
reinforcement learning where an agent
starts with a clean slate or very little
initial knowledge about the world but it
has to learn from interaction with its
environment so for example try a certain
action and then learn about the
consequences of that action in that
world but within the Malmo platform not
only work on reinforcement learning is
supported but within Malmo we aim to
support all types of artificial
intelligence research so we provide
opportunities for more symbolic
reasoning approaches all the way to the
reinforcement learning type of
approaches that I mentioned earlier so
we've talked about researchers using
deep learning Forks
Laura Torre AI y is Malmo a good
platform for this so reinforcement
learning is the general technique and
then deep reinforcement learning is a
specific part of that where you learn
from very high dimensional observations
so for example if you wanted to directly
learn how to interpret visually signals
that come from the environment then you
would use what's called deep
reinforcement learning to use that using
neural networks then exploration is a
really key part within that it's one of
the key challenges in reinforcement
learning to understand how an agent that
is thrown into some arbitrary complex
world can collect new experiences so can
collect data about this world in such a
way that it learns to understand what
kind of tasks what kinds of course it
could achieve within that world talk a
little bit about the importance of
simulation when we're working with AI
agents before they hit the open world so
E is and specifically when we're talking
about reinforcement learning agents that
learn from direct interaction with an
environment they essentially learned
from trial and error so they need to try
some action and some of those might fail
and they need to observe the negative
consequences of those actions in order
to form a good understanding about how
the world works now if we were to think
about safety critical applications like
flight or self-driving cars or maybe the
health space then we want to make sure
that if agents Explorer they only try
those actions that are actually sensible
and have a good chance of success within
those environments just like people do
we wouldn't try arbitrary random things
we would try to address a problem by
taking a path forward that has a good
chance of giving us a good outcome so we
would like those agents to be pre
trained as much as possible in a
simulated environment where the agents
can explore and learn from trial and
error without having negative
consequences for real-world environments
in a robotics case this could be
avoiding crashing a simulator or
crashing a robot but once the system has
learned from this
simulated environment then the key
question is how to transfer that to the
real environment and there's actually a
lot of work many other colleagues are
focusing on that to look at how well
learned behavior can be translated into
real-world situations and in many cases
it's surprisingly effective to actually
pre train and simulation and then
perform the task in a real-world
environment so let's talk a bit about
this reinforcement learning we've talked
to other researchers about the rewards
and punishments but how does an
algorithm deal with rewards different
from a human right we would feel
embarrassed or ashamed or whatever that
we made a mistake an algorithm doesn't
have those feelings what is the
mechanism that you build into the
machine learning techniques for
reinforcement learning that's a
fantastic question and there are two
ways in which I think about how this
agents handle rewards one side of this
is kind of the reward structure that is
imposed on the agent in this case often
by the experiment or by the person
designing a system so if you play a game
let's say a parkour race and Minecraft
then the experimenter could look at this
and say well if you win the race then
you get a positive rewards that we want
to encourage that behavior we give a +1
if you do then you get a -1 so this is
very much
kind of a hint to int reward structure
that would be application dependent in
some situations there might be a reward
structure that is very natural so when
you play Atari games the score was a
pretty good proxy reward structure or if
you learn to play chess then winning or
losing the game is a good one but there
are many application areas where there's
not an obvious reward structure if he
wanted to train an agent to help a human
user perform whatever the user is trying
to do then you would need to think more
generally about what is a good reward
structure for such an agent that learns
to cooperate with people and this is
actually one of the key directions that
we're focusing on within my group to
understand how to create reward
structures that would be useful for
learning this kind of cooperative
behavior or the
sort of behavior and agents
[Music]
your team has intentionally made the
Malmo platform open-source and
independent of or agnostic to the
variety of methodologies and programming
languages that researchers or developers
might bring to the table
why have you worked so hard to make this
project so open that's a fantastic
question and if you ask my team it's
quite painful to develop for three
different operating system and at least
five different programming languages but
what we really designed my MOU for was
for this broad exchange between industry
and the academic community AI and
reinforcement learning are fascinating
techniques and this whole area is
developing very very quickly but it's
not quite clear where the next new
insight is going to come from they're
thousands of people maybe you know
hundreds of thousands of people working
on tackling some of those really hard
challenges and it's often hard to
compare very different approaches with
each other because the different
communities might have different tools
might be using different programming
languages might be using different
benchmarks so we were really envisioning
this as a meta platform that others
could be using to start to compare start
to integrate the different approaches
and really generate new insights and
understanding how to push this area
forward so you eluded just now to
collaboration with academia industry and
academia collaborating what does each
party bring to the party so to speak in
this back and forth between applied in
pure research I think that's a great
question and it's one where I kind of
think of myself as a little bit in the
middle as kind of having a foot in both
because at Microsoft Research we are
really in the research area so some of
our work very much looks like what would
happen at an academic institution but at
the same time we have access to this
huge company where there's a lot of
interesting problems in product groups
and you know looking at people who are
solving some of the really hard
challenges that are experienced in
industry and that gives us a great
source of
both collaboration and inspiration of
what's coming maybe what key challenges
need to be addressed and how we can
frame our research or maybe think about
our research in such a way that it can
achieve maximal input so really thinking
about well if I focus on this area and
answering those questions how is this
going to change the world how is this
going to change how we look at things
and what kind of real world impact could
that have
and I think this real-world perspective
is something really valuable that the
industry side brings to the table on the
academic side you have the opportunity
to take a longer-term view I mean some
of the breakthrough technologies that
we're using today deep learning has
roots that go several decades back and
have taken a huge amount of dedication
and energy of really a sustained
research program on the academic side
and I think this long-term view as well
as the huge variety of different
opinions and ideas that we see in the
academic community are extremely
valuable and absolutely necessary for
pushing the field forward by bringing
those two sides together I think really
interesting things can happen when you
launched project Malmo a year ago you
had a really overwhelming response and
since then there have been some exciting
new developments with the project tell
us what happened at the outset what's
happened since in what you're seeing on
the horizon in the future so we were
really excited more than a year ago and
launching the platform and really seeing
how the community would respond and what
they would do with it and I was really
crazy and exciting to see how many
people would pick up this platform and
use it for your charity of different
purposes some of those we had never
thought about her never anticipated
there was quite some uptake in class
projects to learn about concepts in AI
and different approaches to AI there are
different enthusiasts that are just
loved interacting with the platform and
seeing what they can come up with and
there's a huge variety in terms of the
research directions that people are
establishing on top of it at the same
time people asked about using specific
benchmarks within the platform and this
is what motivated us to really start
looking at what benchmarks we would like
to create
in order to facilitate research and some
of the key research areas that we think
of as the most challenging at this point
in time so out of that discussion
initially came the first mono
collaborative AI challenge which we ran
last year maybe some of the listeners
remember the Pig case task that we run
there which was a fantastic experience
and we had very motivated participants
from all over the world but also give us
a lot of new insights new learnings
about what went well what could be
improved and how to move into a next
round of creating a challenge that could
have a more targeted impact on the
research community so since then we
started reaching out we've build up a
network of academic collaborators which
we are very proud to work with and those
are teams at Queen Mary University in
London as well as EPFL the University
and Lausanne and we put our heads
together and looked at specifically the
question of generality so how can we
create a benchmark that would push the
research towards learning approaches
that would learn not just to perform
well on a single task with maybe a
single opponent and a multi agent
scenario but that would really be
pushing those approaches towards multi
task mighty agent learning in this video
game setting that we're providing here
that's actually quite exciting and
challenging right it's very challenging
yes do you have another challenge coming
up or have you already launched another
challenge absolutely we're just about to
launch the Marlow competition which is
the multi agent reinforcement learning
competition and mammal I believe by the
time this podcast comes out it will
already have been launched but we're
just preparing the platform for actually
releasing the competition how did you
come up with the name Malmo so this was
geographically inspired as you may know
home of minecraft is Stockholm where the
game was originally developed and
initiated and my team is here in
Cambridge in the UK and my MO is almost
in the middle between those it's not a
precise fit but it was the closest at
kind of large city that we found and I
hear that Tamamo is a very energetic
young city with a lot of exciting things
happening so it seems like a very good
fit that's great and just a side
question how would you define who your
audience is for the Malmo challenges so
for the competition's we are targeting
students in particular so we think
students who have maybe had some
experience with reinforcement learning
or machine learning and are trying to
test out to their skills this would be a
fantastic competition to try out what
they've learned and maybe push things
forward we think that the benchmark is a
serious one for the Academy community so
we'd love to see exciting new research
in mighty agent mighty task learning to
be inspired by this so certain
techniques in AI research like current
exploration and probabilistic modeling
are tackling the big problems of
ambiguity complexity and uncertainty and
a lot of interesting work in this area
is coming out of the cambridge lab how
are you seeing these probabilistic
models affect the work that you're doing
i think this is a fantastic area where
two research areas that used to be quite
distinct from each other are starting to
move more closely together if you think
about reinforcement learning as learning
from trial and error then you need to
think very deeply about uncertainty so
if you already know what effects
reactions will have in some environment
then there's no need to explore you
already know everything you need to know
and you can just compute or develop an
optimal strategy for acting in this
environment but a lot of times the
experience of the agent will be very
limited and then it's crucial to have a
good estimate or be able to quantify
that uncertainty and whether uncertainty
is due to not having seen enough data in
a particular part of the environment or
whether there's true store custody so
for example the difference between
playing a slot machine and exploring a
dark cave in one example you see there's
a lot of uncertainty about the outcome
but it's because the slug machine is
really random in the other one there is
of uncertainty just because he may be at
the entrance of the cave and you just
haven't explored the space yet and a lot
of recent work and probabilistic
modeling especially around stochastic
neural networks is taking very rapid
steps forward towards capturing those
different kinds of uncertainty and there
is a very clear application area in
reinforcement learning some key
questions on how to effectively use
those models to inform exploration and
acting in uncertain environments so talk
a bit more I know you have a working
paper on stochastic neural nets and
generative models talk a little bit more
about what you're exploring here you
personally one working paper we have on
the archive right now is looking at
variation of models for model-based
reinforcement learning so the question
we asked there is whether starting with
some initial set of data it would be
more effective and efficient to learn a
model of that environment and then
compute or derive a structure of how to
act or whether what's called model free
approaches that directly learn a mapping
to policy so directly map to an agent's
behavior would be more effective and
there we found first of all that these
types of models can very effectively
learn the structure of the environment
but also that we're particularly able to
use those models in situations where the
environment might be changing so one
scenario is if you get to initially
explore the environment but you may not
have any information about the task or
the reward structure then we're able to
show that we can leverage these models
to learn effectively even before we see
the reward structure and that the agent
can then effectively combine this with
new information and perform the task
very well even with a limited amount of
data
[Music]
we're told over and over that AI has
great potential to benefit the world but
there's a lot of speculation about what
it will actually look like especially if
we enable agents on a large scale to
learn and make decisions maybe even
independent of humans and you're doing
work that enables AI agents to learn and
make decisions so is there anything
about that that keeps you up at night
and if so what are you doing about it
with all new technology that is
initially poorly understood there are a
lot of open questions and a lot of
uncertainty as you note especially with
reinforcement learning technology we
still don't have a lot of good examples
of actually seeing this kind of
technology deployed in real-world
applications and there's key questions
around how we can make sure that all
those decisions that the agent learns to
make are warranted and that we can
explain and understand why they made
those decisions if those are agents that
learn to make decisions in a way that
allows them to interact quite directly
with humans so much more flexibly than
we're currently used to how can we make
sure that those decisions and those
interactions are actually intelligible
to the users and that we have some way
of understanding when an agent is
learning something new and how our
interaction with it affects what its
learning those are really hard questions
and I think this is one reason why video
games are such a fantastic platform for
studying those kinds of technologies
they provide the sandbox where we can
safely explore what it means to interact
with something that is learning to
interact with you and how to frame that
whole learning process and that
interaction and make sure that we can
understand what's going on there you
have an incredibly interesting
personal life story that includes
first-hand experience of what I would
say is one of the biggest events of the
20th century tell us a bit about your
life from your beginnings and what got
you interested in computer science and
how did you come to be doing research at
Microsoft Research in England so I was
born in East Germany so I spent the
first years of my life actually behind
the Iron Curtain and I am old enough to
remember some of this and it's I think
it's quite shaped Who
as a person initially there was this
conviction that there's all these
countries that I would never travel to
and my mom is a geography teacher so she
used to tell us about all these
countries in the world and it was just
completely infeasible for us to even
think about ever visiting them and then
once the wall it opened up all those
opportunities since life you know travel
to all control all continents except for
Antarctica I was studied in three
different countries worked in four so
you know it's just created all this life
stories that you know when I was a
little girl I could have never imagined
anything like this so it's quite
interesting to reflect on this I think
it's also impacted how I came to
encounter computers and the GDR there
weren't a lot of computers so personal
computers only became available after
the Wall fell and that means that when I
was growing up when I was a teenager and
my parents bought a computer because
they you know heard that that could be
something useful there were no
preconceptions about what you can and
cannot do using a computer or there
weren't any role models that would have
influenced me and it was this box that
stood in my room and that I could just
use completely freely and figure out
what it can do I taught myself how to
program and started exploring what's
possible there and I think this kind of
freedom and sense of creativity and
being able to explore really shaped my
my perspective of computing and really
influenced this decision to pursue
computer science later on so from that
room and your three countries of study
how did you end up at Microsoft Research
it almost feels like that was by
accident again wouldn't have anticipated
this but during my PhD I was working in
an area called information retrieval so
I was looking at how to make search
engines more intelligent and one of the
threats that was already present was to
understand how search engines could
learn from the users to be better able
to surface exactly what the user is
looking for so it had the some theme of
interactive learning combined
with search applications one of the
people that I really admired was working
here at Microsoft Research in Cambridge
and I introduced myself at a conference
and we chatted about this work that led
to an internship at Microsoft Research
and Bing in Redmond at the time and gave
me this opportunity to explore what
possibilities there were and what it
meant to be working at Microsoft
Research that was a fantastic experience
so when I was asked whether I wanted to
apply for a postdoc position here I was
thrilled and that was the top choice
that I had well as we close Katya I like
to ask researchers what advice they
would give to other aspiring researchers
especially those who might be interested
in the kind of research you're doing in
machine intelligence and perception and
I'm especially interested in what you'd
say to young women who might be
considering following in your footsteps
that's a very very big question answer
what I'd like to see more in researchers
is thinking more about why we do what we
do academic and intellectual curiosity
is one thing but the research that we do
in the AI and machine learning has such
huge potential to change the world and
you won't be that an expert in the field
or someone on the street will tell you
that AI will have a fundamental impact
on people's lives so I'd like to
encourage people to think more about
what matters about the research why
they're doing this research and how we
should be using it to influence and make
sure that the world we create is the one
we actually want to live in in the
future just drilling in a little bit you
don't see a lot of women proportionally
in machine learning research what do you
think was instrumental in getting you
interested in going that field I think
what played a big part was that I had
this opportunity to just completely
freely discover this area and figure out
what it meant for me before being
confronted with maybe preconceptions and
ideas that people had about what
computing was and what it was for and
who it was for
and I see a lot of the imbalance that
we're seeing today very much reflecting
these preconceptions that people have
I'd love to play a part in changing
those preconceptions I think they are
incredibly hurtful and prevent very
bright very talented people who would
work really hard to make an impact on
this field and sometimes prevent them
from entering the field yeah it's hard
to derive specific advice from that ya
know and they try to isolate yourself
from but everyone thinks and that's not
an easy thing to do no but you know what
right now I think you are an inspiration
on what can be done and what you throw
stuff so Katja Hoffman thank you so much
for taking time at the end of your day
in the beginning of mine to come on the
podcast today thank you so much for
having me it was a great pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
to learn more about dr. Katja Hoffman
and how project Malmo is pushing the
state-of-the-art in reinforcement
learning visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]